i think the stoics
talked about the uh i mean in general
just memento mori like just thinking
about death
and meditating on death is a really
positive
not a positive it's an enlightening
way to uh live life
so what do you think about that at the
uh and the individual level
like what is the role about being
bringing that
terror of death fear of death to the
surface
and being cognizant of it for us that's
the
that's the ball game um so
what we write in our book and here we're
just
um paying homage to the philosophers and
theologians that come before us
is to point out that
literally since antiquity um
there has been a consensus
that to lead a
full life requires um
albert camus said come to terms with
death
thereafter anything is possible
and so you've got the the stoics and you
got the
epicureans and then you got the tibetan
book of the dead
and then you got like the medieval monks
that
you know worked with like a skull on
their desk
and the whole idea i should back up a
bit because and just
remind folks that our studies you know
when we remind people that they're gonna
die
and we find that yeah they drink more
water if the famous person
um is is you know advertising it
uh they eat more cookies they
want more fancy clothes they sit closer
to people that look like them
it changes who they vote for but all of
those things
those are very subtle death reminders
you don't even know that death is on
your mind
and so our point is is that and this is
kind of counterintuitive
and that is that the most
problematic and unsavory human reactions
to death anxiety
are malignant manifestations of
repressed
death anxiety you know we try and bury
it under the psychological bushes and
then it comes back to bear bitter fruit
but what the theologians and the
philosophers of the world
are saying is it behooves each of us
to spend considerable time you don't
have to be a
goth death rocker you know wallowing
in death imagery to
spend enough time entertaining the
reality of the human condition which is
that
you too will pass to get to the point
well where there is
to lapse into a cliche uh the capacity
for personal transformation
and growth let's go personal for a
second uh
are you yourself afraid of death
yeah i mean and how much do you meditate
on that
thought like maybe your own study of it
is a kind of escape from your own
mortality absolutely lex
so you got it and like if you figure out
death somehow you won't die
so no no uh so my my colleagues and
good friends jeff greenberg and tom
posinski you know we met
in graduate school in the 1970s we've
been doing this work for
40 years and we cheerfully admit
even though it doesn't reflect well on
us
as humans that i should just speak for
myself but
i i feel like there's a real sense in
which
uh doing these studies and writing books
and and lecturing has been
my way of avoiding directly confronting
my anxieties by
turning it into an intellectual exercise
and um and every once in a while
therefore when i think that i'm making
some progress
as a human i have to remind myself that
that is probably not the case
um and that i have at times like all
humans
been more preoccupied with the
implications of these ideas for my
self-esteem
it's like oh we're going to write a book
and maybe we'll get to
go on tv or something well
no that's not the same as to
actually think about it in a way that
you feel it rather than just think it
yeah no did when you were eight that's
exactly right
so when i first read the denial of death
i i was so
literally flabbergasted by it that i
took a leave of absence for a year
and just like did what would be
considered menial jobs
i did construction work i worked in a
restaurant
and i i was just like well wait a minute
if if i if i understand what this guy is
saying
then i'm just a culturally constructed
meat puppet
doing things for reasons that i know not
yeah in order to assuage death anxiety
and that's like that that that's not
acceptable
you